a time when it wasn't expected that
derek henry the titans running back
would have a long-term deal to stay in
tennessee he has a four-year contract
reportedly a 50 million dollar deal with
20. 5.5 million guaranteed and remember
when we hear that
guaranteed just generically guaranteed
that means injury guarantee not full
guarantee the question will be whether
or not the full guarantee is more than
i'm checking my math here
22.61 million dollars because
22.61 million is what henry would have
made this year and next year under the
franchise tag now maybe the full
guarantee will be less than that because
you're a running back there's no
guarantee that you're going to be
healthy enough and effective enough to
get tagged again next year at a 12
million dollar plus number but that's
what essentially you look at from the
standpoint of the calculation this
year's franchise tag next year's
franchise tag how much does the full
guarantee compare to that sum and again
the sum is 22.61
the full guarantee injury guarantee is
25.5 for derrick henry and he's got two
more years where he's committed year to
year
with the tennessee titans and good for
him it's only a four-year deal remember
the back end of these long-term deals
that's just a favor to the team that's a
gift to the team where it has a year to
year option if the players still playing
well we're happy to pay it if he's not
playing well we tear it up there's no
real upside for the player under that
scenario the shorter the deal the better
three-year deal would have been ideal
for
derrick henry four years a nice middle
ground between three and five assuming
that's what the two sides were angling
to get so bottom line is he's under
contract will be a titan this year
undoubtedly a titan next year and then
2022 2023 we'll see depending upon how
effective he continues to be because
this is a physical running back who
takes a pounding and gives a pounding
and you have to wonder how many years he
can continue to do that at a high level
justifying the kind of salary that he'll
be getting on average over the next four
seasons
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports